SPIN arbitrates another precious resource, which is another core service, namely
the CPU. SPIN only decides at a macro level, the amount of time, that is
given to a particular extension. That's
done through the SPIN global scheduler. The
global scheduler interacts with the application
threads package. And application is a loose
term here. It is the extension that is living on top of SPIN. Which
may be an entire operating system or maybe just an application. For
example, let's say, we are running Linux and Vista as two
extensions on top of SPIN. Each maybe given a particular time
slice, say of x milliseconds. How each extension uses
the time that has been given to it for scheduling user-level
processes running inside the operating system is entirely
up to those extensions. And to support the concept of threads in
the operating system and management of time, SPIN provides an abstraction
called strand. The actual operating systems that extend
SPIN will have the threads map to strands. So strand is the unit of scheduling
that SPIN's global scheduler uses, but the semantics of the strand is
entirely decided by the extension. If,
for instance, I'm implementing p-threads, I will
define the semantics of the strand to
be the semantics of the p-thread's scheduler.
And there are event handlers that help in the scheduling that needs to happen in
the extensions. And the kind of events that SPIN provides for this core service
of CPU scheduling are block, unblock, checkpoint,
and resume. And the extensions event handlers
have to give the semantic meaning of
what needs to happen when these event handlers
are called, because these are only interface
functions. What needs to happen when this
interface function is called is up to
the extension. For example, a disk interrupt
handler may result in an unblock event being raised for a particular strand that
was waiting for the disk IO completion.
Similarly, if an application were to make
a system call that is a blocking
system call, then the service that provides that
facility to the application will raise this
block event, which will result in the extension
taking the appropriate action of saving the
state of the currently running process. And putting
it in the appropriate queues that it
has, to wait for that system call completion.
So in a nutshell, what SPIN provides are exactly the kind of
primitives that may be needed by an extension that wants to provide
the service of CPU scheduling. So SPIN only provides the interface function
definitions. The semantics are all up to the extension on how
exactly the scheduling is affected. And all that SPIN does
is to ensure that the extension gets time
on the CPU through this global scheduler that
SPIN has for allocating time to different extensions
that may be concurrently living on top of SPIN.